selon permis journal avec le festival de
la francophonie à mantes-la-jolie
benjamin est un conteur de la guadeloupe
il a rencontré les enfants du val fourré
pour leur raconter les histoires
traditionnelles de son île une façon
pour ces jeunes dont la majorité sont
d'origine étrangère de retrouver leurs
racines valérie war michel rech il était
une fois un bateau amarré sur les quais
de la seine à mantes la jolie
un bateau théâtre et sur le nautilus au
fil de l'eau on raconte des histoires
venues d'ailleurs les cruisers il arrive
de ces gens droit il roule pour enfants
est resté une tradition comme par
exemple dans les pays d'afrique
francophone mais sur la scène de ce jour
là il a vu à jamais les enfants il les
connaît bien
d'habitude les instituteurs là-bas en
guadeloupe
j'ai écouté les histoires au moins pour
la fois par semaine pendant près de
vingt ans il y avait trois rencontres
dans la famille là j'ai vraiment été
bercée par les comptes
j'essaie de partager toutes ces joies
tout ce voyage dans le merveilleux que
j'ai pu faire dans mon enfance le
partager avec d'autres enfants
la nombreuse joue long et le chien à la
violence et alors là je te faisais henry
oui hélas le chef du monde
la grand mère la grand-mère à l'abbé dit
qu'elle savait nager tiers des moteurs
elle tapait pas d'un geste les dauphins
et baleines l'atome est la mieux son
dépit puis l'été jyske rica où les
sables et dans la salle ses enfants
venus du val fourré un quartier où se
côtoient une trentaine de nationalités
des enfants venus d'ailleurs à la
découverte de vieilles histoires de la
tradition francophone
désormais vous avez rendez vous